with only hours left before the election
uh the biden harris ticket has decided
to go
all in on marxism that's their closing
pitch their closing argument
the thing they want voters thinking
about as they head to the polls on
tuesday is this
of course biden harris has always been
all in on marxism as has the whole
democrat party for years now but
what i'm going to play for you now is
perhaps the most direct and explicit
endorsement
of that ideology that we've heard from
any major democrat who's not named
bernie sanders
so here's the video put out by camille
harris on sunday listen to this
so there's a big difference between
equality and equity
equality suggests oh everyone should get
the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same up but you're
still gonna be that far back behind me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need
so that everyone can be on equal
footing and then compete on equal
footing
equitable treatment means we all end up
at the same
[Music]
okay a lot of problems here um let me
let's start with the slightly less
significant one
which is what was up with the background
noise here was that like running water
it sounded like a running water sound
effect like a stream or
something were we supposed to imagine
camella
sitting by a stream on a mountain side
imparting these teachings to her
disciples is that the vibe that we're
going for because it doesn't quite work
she definitely doesn't have the soothing
voice necessary to be a mountaintop guru
in fact the voice and the message would
be much more at home in a gender studies
class maybe a workplace
tolerance and diversity seminar or
something like that
so that didn't really work but more to
the point harris says that equality
is giving people the same amount but
that's not good enough she says because
some people are starting out ahead and
so when they get the same amount
they're gonna still be ahead of those uh
who who started out behind them
so what we need she says is equity which
means we all
start at the same place and end at the
same place
and i think that basically summarizes
her argument fairly i think
now let's run through all the reasons
why this is a horrifying combination of
stupid incoherent dishonest and
dangerous number one
equality does not mean that we all get
the same amount that's not
that's not what equality is legally or
in any other sense
equality under the law which is the only
kind of equality that the government
should be concerned with
means that we're all subject to the same
laws and that the law does not
explicitly give advantages or
disadvantages
to anybody which means for example
affirmative action
those laws infringe on equality under
the law they are a direct assault on
equality under the law
by design but that's what equality under
the law is supposed to mean
and that's what we should have in this
country though we don't
equality as it relates to human beings
and societies
more generally though doesn't and cannot
exist in any other form
human beings are not in any measurable
or quantifiable sense
actually equal we should be treated
equal under the law but as far as what
and who we actually are
there's no equality there equality means
sameness i'm not the same as anyone else
on earth
i have a different personality
background experience
i'm either going to be dumber smarter
more hard-working less hard-working more
virtuous less virtuous than the next guy
none of us are equal the type of equity
harris talks about assumes
that we are all equal we're all the same
it doesn't account for any differences
in personality character intelligence
priority
virtue it just assumes that we're all at
heart
exactly the same and crucially that
we're all trying to go
to the same place in her vision of the
world everybody wants to climb to the
same mountaintop
to the same elevation and the same exact
destination
she can't understand that that everyone
has their own mountaintops
and not everyone is trying to get to the
top or people have a different idea of
what the top
is for them and this confusion comes up
quite a bit i think especially with
discussions of the wage gap the wage gap
is mostly a myth of course but
whatever wage disparity does exist
between genders
it's because women and men have
different make different choices
in their careers they have different
priorities women for example are
more likely to choose jobs that give
them more time at home
they're more likely to leave the work
force entirely to raise children
harris sees this as a problem of equity
what you can't understand is that lots
of women
make that choice because that's the kind
of life they want to live
that's their priority their vision their
desire their mountaintop
it's not the same as everybody else
number two
what does she mean by get the same
amount
same amount of what and who is giving it
is this this isn't being pedantic here
it's a serious question
i honestly have no idea what this thing
is that we're all getting and who's
giving it
what does she mean money skill iq points
what are we talking about here
but of course the vagueness is the point
harris can just shout
we should all get the same amount and
undiscerning listeners will cheer yes
sounds great the same amount without
anybody stopping to ask
uh wait a second um same amount of what
number three bringing us to the most
terrifying part of the clip i think she
says
equitable equitable treatment means we
all end up
at the same place this is what's known
as equality of
outcome equality of opportunity is
usually what politicians talk about even
though that phrase and that concept
is also vague and impossible to achieve
or even to define but
but that's one thing equality of outcome
is another thing entirely equality of
opportunity in theory means that
you know you you clear the path and let
people walk as far down it as they want
equality of outcome means you set booby
traps on the path to stop
some people from walking too far down it
and then you take other people and you
carry them further along it
so that at the end we're all bunched up
some of us bruised and bleeding
on the same spot on the same path and
who chooses what that spot should be
who decides what our universal outcome
ought to be who decides
where we should all end up well the
government of course camilla harris
she'll be happy to decide and as the
decider that means that she is not
herself in the same place
she's further along she has power so
everyone else
should end up in the same place but not
her she needs to be further along
so that she can turn around and decide
where the rest of us are allowed to go
how far we're allowed to go so this is
full-blown marxism
and to understand how disturbed you
should be by it
just imagine what would be required for
the government to ensure that 330
million people
all end up in the same place well you
don't have to imagine
look elsewhere in the world and
throughout history where this experiment
has been tried you will find tyranny and
death
because tyranny and death is
these are a necessary mechanism a
vehicle for
for what camille harris is talking about
you cannot create equality of outcome
without removing self-determination
freedom liberty creativity
everything else that makes humans human
and life worth living
see the thing is governments really
cannot force people
to be more successful than their desire
ambition and skill level will take them
government cannot create equity through
positive enforcement
the only way it can do it is to do the
one thing governments can do which is
punish
censor stifle kill governments cannot
force people to be successful
they can though steal the fruits of
success from the successful
and chop them back down to size this is
within the logistical capabilities of
the government
even if it's not within its moral or
constitutional limits
so that's what this equity will mean
that's what it always means
punishment and suppression that's the
future the democrats envision
now voters have to decide if it's what
they want as well
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content